93% des français acheté un produit made
in france participe au maintien de
l'emploi sur le territoire national ils
sont même 73 % à se déclarer prêts à
payer un peu plus cher un produit
fabriqué en france selon l'insee le made
in france représente dans le secteur du
textile près de 40000 emplois et un
chiffre d'affaires annuel de plus de 7
milliards d'euros l'industrie françaises
de l'habillement représentent-elles plus
de 40000 emplois et plus de 8 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires annuel et
l'habillement français s'exporte
un chiffre en progression de 8 % chaque
année depuis la crise de 2009 dans un
secteur qu'on connaît bien dans la
région celui du marché du jouet seuls 7%
des jouets vendus sont fabriqués sur le
territoire national les jouets et jeux
sont donc massivement importé le temps
dans la grande distribution en moyenne
un produit sur trois a distribué est
d'origine française cela varie selon les
secteurs
40% dans l'alimentaire 22% pour les
produits manufacturés